amid reports of counter-attacks against
russian forces on different fronts
ukrainian troops around the capital kiev
say they've retaken territory even
threatening to cut off stranded units of
russians there is through
big battle
and from official sources we received
information right now the
small city macariff
and
almost
whole airplane
already in the control is ukrainian
soldier
russia increasingly seems to be relying
on missile and rocket attacks as its
ground forces become bogged down and the
russian ministry of defense has released
footage of its cruise missiles launched
from land and sea that have been
striking targets throughout ukraine
while russian forces may have been held
in the north and even driven back by
counter-attacks according to the
ukrainians in the south greater strength
and organization appear to be helping
russia make a bigger impact on the
battlefields there
in the besieged city of mariupol
ukrainian defenders say they still hold
a perimeter in the center but new drone
footage shows the scale of the
devastation
while it's still difficult for people to
get out and for humanitarian aid to get
in both sides continue to operate nine
humanitarian corridors in other parts of
the country
meanwhile ukrainian president vladimir
zelensky has continued his global charm
offensive this time addressing members
of japan's parliament via video link
as with other direct appeals to the
international community he deftly
tailored his message
following the offensive on the zaporizia
nuclear plant earlier in the conflict he
touched upon japan's own experience of
nuclear attacks to muster support for
his country's cause
there are four operating nuclear power
plants on our land there are 15 nuclear
units and they are all under threat
while both sides seem to be experiencing
successes and setbacks in the military
struggle in the fight for international
support it's ukraine that appears to be
making the most recent gains
rob mcbride al jazeera level